[Music]  ah hey you please stop bothering like  him so  Arthur I have some bad news for you this  is the last time we'll be meeting you  don't listen dear you just ask the same  questions every week how's your job are  you having any negative thoughts all I  have are negative thoughts  and finally in a world where everyone  thinks they could do my job check out  this guy  when I was a little boy and told people  I was gonna be a comedian everyone  laughed at me well no one's laughing now  you can say that again  [Music]  so hospital isn't it  [Music]  for my whole life  if I even really existed  but I do  starting to notice  I think this is funny  to joke to you  very one small thing yeah when you bring  me out can you introduce me as Joker  [Music]  send in the cloud  [Music]  you